Venom 2 is gonna be a scream well, almost.
According to a new report by Deadline, Sony
Pictures has selected a second villain to
feature in the forthcoming Venom sequel, which
will be directed by Andy Serkis and star returning
actor Tom Hardy as the man possessed by the
titular symbiote.
Deadline cites two sources with knowledge
of Venom 2 who have indicated that the Marvel
Comics villain Shriek will be a part of the
film's plot.
With Shriek incorporated into the script,
the forthcoming Venom sequel slated to launch
in theaters on October 2, 2020 will feature
at least two infamous comic book villains.
The first is Cletus Kasady, a serial killer
who serves as the host for the extraterrestrial
symbiote called Carnage.
In the comics, Kasady is shipped off to Ryker's
Island Maximum Security Penitentiary after
murdering 11 people.
There, he actually shares a cell with Eddie
Brock, who was incarcerated after wreaking
havoc across New York City as Venom.
Kasady and Brock quickly form a deep hatred
for one another, with Brock despising Kasady
for killing people he knew were innocent and
helpless.
Things take a horrifying turn when it's revealed
that Brock's symbiote Venom isn't dead but
merely dormant.
When it reforms with Brock, it leaves a sort
of offspring stuck on Kasady.
That entity turns into a full-fledged symbiote
of its own, bonds to Kasady, and becomes Carnage.
In the first Venom film, these events play
out a little differently.
Woody Harrelson is seen as Cletus Kasady in
a mid-credits scene, in which Eddie Brock
visits him in prison on an interview assignment.
Kasady says the line that makes everyone say,
“OH!
That’s who the guy with the terrible wig
is!
"When I get outta here, and I will, there's
gonna be carnage."
Since it was basically a no-brainer that Carnage
would be in Venom 2, many fans speculated
that Shriek, Carnage's love interest, might
appear in the flick as well.
Shriek's real name is Frances Louise Barrison,
and she made her print debut in May 1993's
Spider-Man Unlimited #1 during the Maximum
Carnage comic storyline.
She's introduced as a drug dealer with a troubled
past who gets busted by the vigilante duo
Cloak and Dagger in the middle of one of her
drug runs.
After being imprisoned in the Ravencroft Institute
for the criminally insane, getting shot in
the head by a police officer, and spending
time in Cloak's Darkforce Dimension, Frances
has a few screws loose.
Her descent into insanity brings her latent
mutant abilities to the surface allowing her
to fly, manipulate sound, shoot sonic energy
blasts from her hands, and access others'
minds to manipulate their emotions and force
them to act violently.
In the comics, Carnage meets Shriek as he's
breaking free from Ravencroft, where Shriek
is also being held.
The two make their violent escape, team up,
embark on a gruesome killing spree, and create
a makeshift "family" with the villainous Carrion,
Demogoblin, and Doppelgänger.
It's possible that Venom 2 may place Shriek
inside San Quentin Penitentiary, but still
see her meet Carnage when he's escaping.
This would set up a fantastically frightful
storyline for the two villains, who may or
may not assemble a group of antagonistic pals
in the new movie.
Perhaps a bigger question than how Shriek
will fit into the Venom 2 narrative is which
actress will fit into the role itself.
There's no news yet, but Deadline's sources
say that Sony is primarily looking at unknown
actresses for the time being.
Whoever ends up playing Shriek in Venom 2
will definitely share the screen with top
talent.
In addition to starring opposite Woody Harrelson
as Carnage and Tom Hardy as Venom, the Shriek
actress will appear alongside Michelle Williams
as Anne Weying, Brock's ex-fiancée.
Let's just hope that the lucky lady who lands
the role for Venom 2 will get to wear a better
wig than the wild one Harrelson sported in
the first Venom flick.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.